let me ask you then uh based on what
your dad was saying
you mentioned um jim crow's self
your father they wouldn't give him work
outright slurring adam
why don't you first i guess the question
is what do you think systemic racism is
and then why would you say there isn't
any well systemic racism means top-down
stuff uh the way it used to be during
jim crow
uh i'd ask you to give me the example of
of a corporation fortune 500 corporation
an institution uh college media uh uh
military where there's top down racism
you can't come up with it the the the uh
media is really relentlessly left-wing
academia same thing the military uh is
quite diverse
give me give me the name name the
corporation whenever whenever there's a
corporation where somebody says
something arguably racist like texaco
did a few years ago ceo on tape
referring to the employees as i don't
think he said n word but he said
something disparaging goes on tv
apologizes texaco loses
hundreds of millions of dollars in
equity uh and then they end up having a
program to advance the uh
the careers of the black employees of
texaco
papa john remember he was on a call one
time he said something
he was quoting somebody else and said
the n word lost his own company
uh there john there's a guy named john
o'sullivan he used to be the editor of
the national review he said white racism
exists but its social power is weak the
social power against it overwhelming
there's no upside today in any
corporation
blatantly openly even subtly being
racist so let me let me uh get your
thoughts on this i was uh i was down
covering the ferguson riots back when
the michael brown stuff happened and i
did a documentary on what people they
refer to as systemic racism
what they what how it was explained to
us is st louis is actually a very small
city
outside of st louis and st louis county
actually it's it's like 90 some odd
cities right these cities were formed uh
when uh are you familiar with pruitt i
go
it was one of the first if not the first
um
like uh
community housing project housing and it
was in st louis
and one once it fell into disrepair you
started to get crime in the area things
started to get bad and white people in
st louis started to flee the city and
then form new new surrounding suburbs i
bet you middle class blacks also fled
the city
it's possible
but so what happens today is
you have areas that are
you you end up uh seeing
racially
fractured communities one area is all
white they had racial covenants which
were eventually made illegal but then
you have you know a white grandfather
gives it to his son who gives it to his
you know son or whatever you have areas
that are predominantly white black or
otherwise what ends up happening is
you have impoverished black people as a
result of a lot of these policies
because of the way the cities are set up
they should move
well and nothing stopping them from
moving move we interviewed people and
asked them about it and they said move i
i
lived in cleveland for a number of years
and i remember uh when i first got there
in 1977 there was a newscast of all
these white people living in akron uh
where there was 25 unemployment
complaining about the steel mills uh
going going away rust belt and i was
looking at the television i said move
move move but what's stopping you from
moving get out of jail
so what do you mean jail so i want to
get your thoughts on on with their
accusation on their claims
what ends up happening is something they
call going on tour
where if you have a busted tail light
and you drive from your town four miles
to your job you go through four or five
cities you get pulled over in each one
you get a ticket in each one and then
you go on tour through their jails where
one twenty dollar infraction you can't
pay for turns into four weekends in jail
where they keep trading you the next the
police stations
so
this is this is what they refer to as
remnants of racial covenants which
created multiple jurisdictions which
have a negative impact on people today
okay we did ask people why don't you
move the area well people who have
negative bank accounts i mean
theoretically could just start walking
but i think for a lot of people that
they don't know or it's just not
reasonable i suppose i'm not saying that
is systemic racism it's what they claim
is systemic racism and it's how i of
course followed ferguson greatly and the
obama white house comes in and they
accuse the ferguson pd of being
systemically racist for the reasons that
you mentioned it turns out that ferguson
is 67 black but 85 of the traffic stops
were of black people 18 point gap ergo
systemic racism
apply that same logic to new york new
york is 25 black but almost 55 percent
of the traffic stops are black people
that's a 30 point gap even bigger than
ferguson yet nypd offices street
officers majority of them are people of
color turns out that obama did a study
called race and traffic stop came out in
2013 by the national institutes of
justice which is a research arm of the
doj and you name the traffic offense a
black motorist was more likely to
violate it whether it was speeding
driving without uh without a with an
expired tag driving without the proper
headlight uh driving without a seat belt
driving without a child safety seat in
the back when you have a kid you name
the offense black motorists were more
likely to commit the offense stop
committing crimes if your if your pal if
your tail light is busted fix it don't
expect people to give you some slack
just because you're black fix it
take responsibility the so the response
we got was that if you have to choose
between paying for gas or registering
your plate or whatever people are going
to choose probably to pay for the guests
to move the car knowing that they're
going to get you know they run the risk
the issue is the structure of the
jurisdictions turning one infraction
into four which then results in you get
a ticket you can't pay it's 50 bucks you
say well i couldn't pay for the 20
registration i can't pay for the 50 fine
so the police come and they say you're
going to spend a weekend in jail then
but the moment you get out of jail the
next department is waiting right outside
saying you're coming to us next so what
they refer to as institutional racism is
not that the individual officers are
being racist but that due to the
remnants of the past
there are negative consequences for
people who live in this jurisdiction
jurisdiction today and they don't know
what to do to stop it solve it or get
out
again i would just say it's a real
simple solution don't commit crimes uh
in in baltimore where freddie gray died
freddie gray died in police custody
remember he was the one who was in the
van yeah
there were six officers who were
prosecuted three of the officers were
black the state attorney who brought the
charges with black city council was all
democrat majority black the mayor was
black number one number two running the
police department black
the u.s attorney general at the time
loretta lynch is black as was the
president
now these are black people running the
entire system and still people are
talking about it being systemically
racist i'm reminded of that joke that
wanda sykes said
how are you going to complain about the
man when you are the man
and
i'd like to know what the officials are
in st louis who they are in all these
areas my suspicion is they're regular
people trying to do their jobs and
they're not bigots
i i just think this is difficult you can
still say the system's broken you can
still say that people should not be
dying in police custody you can still
say that cops need better training
but do them on a case-by-case basis
that's what i'm saying it should be case
by case and it always has to be all or
nothing when we're screaming at each
other on twitter but like a lot of times
it's not racism it's that cop didn't
train jiu-jitsu and doesn't know how to
put on a proper choke holder doesn't
know when a person is completely out and
just needs to be trained there's a city
in in uh california called rialto
realtors around 100 000 people racially
it reflects the demographics of
california the same percentage of
hispanics blacks asians his and whites
and the cops a few years ago were
ordered to wear body cams they didn't
want to at first
and they wore them after a year what
happened
police complaints fell 90
and police use of force fell 50 not
because the police were engaging in any
kind of different uh activity they were
they behaved as they always were always
been trained civilians stopped lying on
them
and they started complying and as a
result the police didn't need to use the
force anymore they stopped filing
lawsuits
and because it is
illegal to file a false lawsuit against
a cop so it turns out the civilians were
the ones who were making a bunch of
false allegations as did michael brown
during ferguson uh michael brown's
friend who said hands up don't shoot
turned out to be a complete lie even
obama it was uh i think holder uh eric
holder is a uh
department of justice
at the time yeah and it turns out that
um
the michael brown's dna was on the
officer's gun he tried to get the gun
and his friend i think his name was
dorian johnson or something said that my
friend said hands up don't shoot and it
turns out a complete and total lie they
lied the police are lied on all the time
and when they got busted because of
rialto they stopped doing it i just
wanted to circle back real quick to what
you were saying about
actually what tim was saying about this
kind of
when you feel like you're you're
underwater right i don't have money to
to get out of these situations i think a
lot of what we're talking about right
now
it's institutional problems right it's
the government welfare state we're we're
doing a lot of talking about them but
for people
listening to the show
right
before
you have a kid before you're ready or
split um on the mom before you end up in
a situation i mean man i've been in
situations where
you just feel like
you just feel like checking out is the
only answer where it's you know you're
broke and you finally get a thing and
then that falls through and then you
just keep digging digging digging
digging digging what's your because man
i was so touched by the story you told
about your dad
what's your personal advice so forget
the institutions it's real simple
listening uh they're they're probably
the most prominent think tank on the
left is the brooking institution
and one of the ones on the right is
called the american enterprise institute
they don't agree on anything but they
agree on what they call the millennial
success sequence
finish high school
ideally one where you can read write a
compute at grade level that's why i
support school choice but first of all
finish high school don't have a kid
until you're 25 years old until you're
20 years old get married before you have
the kid get a job keep that job any job
even a minimum wage job don't quit until
you get another job within six months
you'll get a raise and finally avoid the
criminal justice system
committing an act of crime is a
voluntary act you don't have to do it
you follow that formula you will not be
poor and you'll get to the middle class
you don't there's a very good chance
you're going to be poor so there's uh i
i i agree mostly i would just say
when it comes to at least where i grew
up they were ignorant of the law is no
excuse for breaking it so i as well as
many other people have found ourselves
unwittingly having committed a crime not
realizing it was because it was
seemingly innocuous like when you get a
ticket when you're driving in illinois
you can keep driving there's no no
problem you got a ticket it's like so
you drive they take your id you keep the
ticket when you get pulled over you show
them the ticket they say okay you pay it
off they send you your id back what i
didn't know because they don't tell you
this in driver's ed or anything is that
if you get two moving violations on the
age of 21 they suspend your license so
sure enough i got a class a misdemeanor
which was a threat of a year in jail and
like a 2 500 fine it wasn't just
something i could avoid i didn't even
know it was happening so that took away
my ability to drive for like two years
because not only was my license
suspended then i got caught driving on a
suspended license which i didn't even
know was suspended and you couldn't
blame systemic racism well so he did
my point is simply though you know
i feel like the system is is
a simple way to put it is it might be
easy to say avoid the law but for a lot
of people the system is just busted yeah
one same with these ways right i was
just gonna say same with um
sex education so much sex education is
not the best in this country and i feel
like especially
for if you're pro-life you should want
the best sex education possible so that
people don't even get into this a
situation where they would even want an
abortion so maybe a lot of it does start
with education when it comes to the law
when it comes to learning the trade when
it comes to sex education i think but
but tim it's hard to go to jail they
don't want you to go to jail especially
when you're young they have all sorts of
programs juvenile programs diversionary
programs it is hard to go to jail you've
got to commit a crime to go to jail
you've got to hurt somebody to go to
jail it's hard to go to jail they don't
want to put you there gavin newsom
released 8 000 convicted felons some of
whom were violent felons because of of
covet they don't want you there
the idea that somebody is hiding behind
a tree with a net looking to snare black
people it's just a it's just a lie for
sure sure but you know and and again i
think we're outside of racism at this
point just talking about you know i i
passed the success i would agree for the
most part uh with you i think the issue
of crime is not even about jail is about
i wasn't able to drive for for so for
for two years on it for this point it's
like that'll make it harder to get a job
i couldn't do anything i was like so i
was like okay i guess i'll go live in
the city where i don't need to drive i
had no choice you're still in america
absolutely still in america where where
people in cuba are braving shark
infested waters to get here where people
from haiti are trying to get here
central america mexico they would love
to trade places with us as we sit here
in mine and now [ __ ] and moan about
relatively minor things now i agree with
you on that my attitude on all this
stuff is when you tell people to move
like that's actually what i did so i had
i did that 200 bucks in my pocket and i
found a ride share to california and i
was like i'll sleep on the beach i don't
care i'm not going to stay in a bad
situation
and so my attitude actually is very much
in line with that so pick up your cards
and play them to the best of your
ability that is your duty that is your
moral obligation i thought it was
interesting that you talked about not
knowing the law about the the tail
wasn't the tail lights or uh uh
suspended license getting right like
it's systemic ignorance maybe of the law
but what it makes me think of when i
think of systemic racism is that 200
years ago all these black people from
africa were slaves and they were
intentionally not educated they were
intentionally not taught to read and
write then they were eventually let out
or whatever slavery ended they had kids
they didn't know how to read and write
they didn't know how to teach their kids
the kids didn't know how to read right
then they had kids and for the most part
education is passed down generation
through the family without that we have
a systemic ignorance problem but they
call it racism just because they happen
to have been from africa those slaves
they could have been
they could have been like italian you
know they just weren't at that time but
maybe there was a reason that their skin
color was dark i just don't think it's a
skin color issue
that's a good point i think the
implication today is
you know often what i talk to people
about is the policies of racism have
like been made illegal and and you
actually can make they're people who
make money suing whenever they perceive
it like right now you've got
these selected videos where a muppet
person won't hug a black kid
but they don't show you the videos where
the muppet people don't hug the white
kids either and things like that they're
just very bad muppets you guys or
whatever you call them i don't know if
they're muppets
it's rosita and it took place at sesame
place in philadelphia uh and there's
video showing rosita high-fiving white
kids ignoring blackheads and when
somebody made the video put it on on web
it went viral and a bunch of other
people who went to sesame place over the
years
found videos where this thing was
happening so maybe something is going on
there but my problem is this uh this 25
million dollar class action lawsuit been
filed jesse jackson writes a letter to
sesame place accuses him of engaging
systemic racism the family that filed a
lawsuit is from baltimore
philadelphia has had black mayors
the
police chief is a black female the
superintendent of school is a black
person
the family from baltimore files a
lawsuit as i mentioned there are 13
public high schools in baltimore where
zero percent of the kids can do math at
grade level zero percent 13 high schools
another half a dozen where one percent
can that's half of all the high schools
in baltimore where the kids in the inner
city are either zero proficient in math
only one percent are proficient jesse
jackson said nothing about that he said
nothing about the fact that philadelphia
where sesame place is is on track to
register the highest number of murders
in the city's history most of them are
black jackson says nothing about that
but he goes ballistic over some
four-year-old kid not being high-fived
by rosita it's ridiculous and whether or
not this kid responds to this in a
sensible way depends entirely upon the
parent to put it in perspective where's
jackson on these other things nowhere do
you think that leads to
more people taking
actual racism less seriously absolutely
it does because it trivializes the whole
the whole word racism well and that's
what i was wondering and that's been one
of the things that has
gotten me so just over so much of the
left it's that if you start conflating
um a sexist joke with sexual assault if
you start conflating the muppet thing
with you know actual hate crimes then
you're getting all of these people that
are just gonna
suddenly they hear the word racism and
they go oh what like that stupid muppet
thing and you're
you're essentially
you're taking away any meaning from it
because
i don't think you're saying that racism
isn't real but the problem is if we're
talking about these fake stories then we
can't actually come up with solutions
about what to do with real racism and i
thought about our friend bill ottman who
did the minds convention that we all
performed at and he actually had because
you were talking about a lot of black
intellectuals not going on your show but
he had coleman hughes on a panel with
cornell west and it was awesome because
they were respectful to each other and
they were both looking for solutions and
i think it is so cowardly
of democratic black intellectuals not to
go on your show because it shouldn't be
about we're just going to shout talking
points at each other if you care about
racism you want all voices from all
political sides to be like hey man
there's a problem what do we do to fix
it but let me just say
as you mentioned
you've got murder you've got homicide
but what are these lawyers going for
perceived slight set up at a wealthy
theme park or something maybe it's just
for the lawsuits well not wealthy we
were poor and couldn't afford disney
world
c-span yesterday yeah for two hours and
a guy calls up black guy and he says you
know i watch a lot of black talk show
hosts and i never see you on any of them
yeah i never see you on uh on roland
martin's show he said uh i never see you
on any of of the shows and i said well i
debated roland martin before the
election i killed him sure uh he has a
radio show he's never invited me on it
um charlemagne the god has a very
popular show yeah
reached out to him to have him come on
my radio show didn't hear back i was
gonna be
a few months ago with a guy named a guy
named bill bellamy sat next to me
yeah yeah yeah yeah
they're up watching him and we had a
long conversation and he said you know
one of my friends is charlie and the guy
why don't you go on this on his show and
i said can you set that up he said yeah
i can do that we exchange information i
never heard back yeah now we want to
just show up knock on the door say hey
interview me right it doesn't work that
way
you got to be invited yeah tim invited
me on this show i didn't just show
up would have been awesome hi tim hi tim
yeah
you got two hours yeah if you showed up
randomly knocked on the door we'd roll
out the red card
you'd be invited that would have been so
funny joy reid hasn't had me on the show
the view hasn't had me on invite me i'm
there yeah
i'm easy to find we have gotten to a
point where everything is so tribalized
that the idea of having
a
black conservative
people are just so used to
i scream by talking points at you you
scream your talking points at me instead
of like hey man no if we all want the
best for these struggling communities
then you need to hear a diversity of
opinions absolutely there's a magazine
called ebony ebony for a time was the
most popular black magazine came out
once a month it still comes out it
doesn't have the same power it has right
now owned by a different family and
every year they had a feature jamie
called the 100 most influential black
americans
and every year excluded from that list
were clarence thomas
thomas soule
who is absolutely brilliant he's he was
once called by david mamet the
playwright america's greatest
contemporary philosopher not included in
ebony and walter williams the first and
only black person that i know of to be
the chairman of an economic department
of a non-historically black college well
they need it they don't even know who
these people are yeah i didn't know i
didn't know thomas sol i didn't yeah and
i knew clarence thomas is like the pube
guy like that that's all we're told on
the left you know what i mean where even
if you disagree with him it's like well
you have a black house how do you
exclude somebody who's on the supreme
court now one of the most influential
black people in america i agree how do
you do that yeah but they did it every
single year and of course i was never in
it and a bunch of other people who are
younger
black conservatives were never in it
yeah thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you